welcome back to ours final panel our
final public panel of the morning I know
that the last panel we had was really
invigorating in the conversation has
been very stimulating and we've been
talking about how cities are competing
with each other but we're going to
continue our approach which is somewhat
cooperative and helpful in sharing
because that's really what global
partners has made itself through its
website and its resource exchange and
through the global partners summits it's
really about sharing innovative ideas
across cities and we actually believe
that that process of sharing will make
us all stronger now in keeping with the
theme of our summit this morning I know
everybody understands that it's simply
impossible to create jobs without
working with the private sector so
because we are focusing from the
perspective of public policy we do
recognize the important role of the
private sector here and we have no
illusions about that but we also want to
say that at the same time business also
needs the support of government we don't
want government to get in the way but
business does need the support of
government to grow and expand and to
innovate and so in this session this
morning we are really fortunate to be
able to hear from today's leaders in
creating public-private partnerships to
enable business growth and job creation
our first speaker is chris from ulan
chris was appointed as the general
manager of bandwidth barn ltd in 2008
this is a cape town-based organization
enabling entrepreneurs to start
successful businesses and develop new
products and he will of course talk more
about bandwidth barn prior to joining
bandwidth barn chris gained extensive
business experience across a number of
sectors and has served in a variety of
executive management
ditions and his field of specialization
is entrepreneurship and development he
has also been instrumental in organizing
Cape Town entrepreneurship competition
excuse me an initiative of the city of
cape town for the past three years it's
a pleasure to welcome him to the global
partner summit and to New York City
Christ to thank you so much and once
again thanks for the for the opportunity
and I'm very honored to be in the
esteemed company that we've that we've
had the spelling and I'm sure that's
still sitting in front of us here when
when repairing for this I I had a lot of
thinking to do and I thought of you know
as an opening to tell you what I'm not
going to tell you in this story and I'm
not going to tell you about you know
economic and the political and social
challenges that we currently face in
South Africa I'm not going to tell you
about drawing unemployment figures I'm
not going to tell you about the growing
or the huge number of drawing a youth
that are unskilled and untrained I'm not
going to tell you about the red tape
that makes it very difficult and very
expensive store to do business in South
Africa and neither will I tell you
anything about the labor market that is
so over regulated at this stage that it
actually discourages small businesses
from employing people and thus creating
jobs thought it would be a good
opportunity to draw the tell you about
our very small organization and with
very limited resources that the work
we've been doing over the past 10 years
in partnership with the city of Cape
Town and also with the department of
economic development of our local
provincial government now I mean if it
comes back to the to the challenges and
so that
I think there is a well-documented and
well researched and a lot of studies
done by organizations like the World
Bank in furtive the Global
Entrepreneurship Institute and and and
the like when we look at the literature
on on business incubation and we've
heard this morning about New York's nine
incubators then the the process for
establishing that is as is well
documented and established and well
described and this usually involves some
government agency or an NGO or an
academic institution to take the lead
and drive initiatives like that in our
case that the story has been completely
different and most people find it
surprising that we have developed from
within the ranks of the entrepreneurial
community themselves who ten years ago a
couple of software engineers getting
together and the sole purpose at that
stage was due to overcome the high cost
of doing business and specifically the
high cost at that stage of of internet
access and they've also the name
bandwidth bandwidth born the the focus
of the organization because of that
background has mainly been around
providing entrepreneurs and startup
companies with infrastructure support
and although the scenario in terms of
doing business and access to internet
and Internet costs and bandwidth costs
has come down and changed quite
significantly over the past couple of
years infrastructure support still
remains a very large pot and a very
important component of the support that
we provide to entrepreneurs in fact i
think the benefit of of the services
that we delivered to our community is
that we provide our mostly previously
disadvantaged group of entrepreneurs
access to facilities
and skills and knowledge that they may
not have otherwise have access to I can
or can afford for for that matter it was
not until five years after our
stablishment into in the year 2000 that
we have for the first time I started
looking at delivering enterprise
development services in terms of
business skills and again that needs
sprung from right within our
entrepreneurial community where when
we've identified that if you look at
technicians and you look at groups of
software engineers and software
developers and graphic designers that
these people are reading specialists and
experts in what they do but they know
very little about business and in order
to take it to the next level we've
identified the need to do to help them
overcome that barrier and focus rather
on business and to enter the club global
arena as innovative and sustainable
businesses as well so we have launched
in 2000 we have launched our first
program called launch pad which was
aimed at importing very basic business
skills to a small start-up group of
about five young companies this was
self-funded in 2006 we had launched our
second program called my mentor we when
we've identified the need of very
specific specialized skills within
businesses that needed the assistance of
subject specialists to unlock and move
those businesses forward but we've also
realized during this time though is that
because of this particular skill set
that is required to to assess these
companies and our limited resources that
we will not be able to develop that
skill set in house and we'll have to
rely on on external resources for
mentorship and for
for for coaching these companies it was
then that we approached the both the
provincial government and the city of
Cape Town to see whether they would be
interested to help us fund those
particular programs now I think at this
point it may be appropriate just to just
to say a little something on on how on
our funding model and our business model
and that is that we do not receive any
operational support or funding support
from any organization or from any
government organization what we what we
generate and we pay our bills by
charging clients normal rental rates on
on the services that we provide but the
enterprise development side of the
business and those programs that we run
our funded to the amount of round about
300,000 dollars per annum by the city of
Cape Town and the provincial government
the we've recently commissioned an
independent impact assessment to see
what the impact on on on on general
economic development and
entrepreneurship development has been
and we are very satisfied and very proud
to say that all the companies that has
moved through some of our programs like
the launchpad velocity program 85 st.
are still in business today the
ninety-eight percent of companies that
we've supported in terms of the
mentoring and coaching program are still
in business today we have seen that
since during the last five but I past
five years these companies had a
combined revenue growth of over three
hundred and twenty eight percent and
today supports in excess of 1,700 direct
and indirect jobs which is a record that
we quite proud of but the one thing that
we that we have realized and that we've
seen coming out of the impact assessment
is that to move
to the next level that we will have to
shift the focus away from from being
overly infrastructure support focus to
really to go to the innovative side and
to really develop innovation and to
focus on innovation coming out of our
universities the difficulty in that is
is that we don't have the resources to
do that by ourselves and once again we
have to return to to our public partners
to see how we could address these issues
now during the celebrations of Captain
Entrepreneurship Week in 2010 professor
Daniel Eisenberg of Babson said that for
in order for cities to really show
sustainable growth that it has to create
at least one I growth potential business
but 100,000 inhabitants every year
professor Eisenberg then also looks at
defining these high growth potential
businesses and saying that these are
businesses with high growth ambition
these are companies with products and
services that has a potential high
market acceptance they have large
potential markets they have good
leadership and they have a global a
global orientation so how then do we as
a small organization through hate to
contribute these then run about 30
businesses per annum that cape town with
its three million population need to
create and the answer to that is very
simple is that we need to be we need to
rid ourselves of our dependency on our
on our rental model so we need to be
freed up from that and therefore we need
resources and the easiest resource to do
that is to have our own facility at this
stage we rent our premises from from a
commercial landlord and if we could rid
ourselves of that model we could
contribute much more
to the develop of entrepreneurship and
small businesses within the captain and
and within the region so the issues that
we currently looking at is how do we
then with our public partners we do have
a huge property portfolios available
some of which is underutilized
completely at this stage and how do we
unlock the political wall and the
political goodwill to help us then
proceed further in creating a great city
and a great region thank you Chris our
next speaker is Ulla Hamilton who is
vice mayor for enterprise traffic and
labor market for the city of Stockholm
and has an extensive background in
politics policy and the private sector
which of course is a requisite for this
panel I think you need to be engaged at
all three levels she's been a member of
the stockholm city council since 1995
and a member of the Council of Mayors
since 2006 and is a former vice mayor
for the environment in traffic and
foreign environment and real estate well
Hamilton is also a former member of
local government councils of upsala and
loaned and before becoming vice mayor
she was communications manager at the
Confederation of Swedish enterprises I
am NOT going to try and pronounce that
in Swedish since I can't even do French
and I studied that she has a BA in law
from upsala University and most of us in
this room know that Stockholm has been a
leader in the innovation economy and in
creating public-private partnerships so
we're delighted to have you here today
and we look forward to your remarks
thank you very much and thank you to the
organizers and to the city of New York
and sponsors for inviting Stockholm to
this and very interesting
and seminar and I as you know so calm
and Sweden is located on a continent
that is becoming less important to world
economic development it's therefore of
very great importance that our offer
from the city from the Stockholm region
to investors and visitors will be as
attractive as possible in order to meet
the global competition as we heard of
here today and Stockholm is as many many
capitals a growing city but and if we
are growing quite rapidly at the moment
and the challenge is how to grow and
develop in sustainable and wrestle and
fashion because we are also very famous
for being a very environmentally
friendly city the city has an overriding
vision 2030 based on the notion that
stokem will continue to grow and the
vision outlines what kind of city we
would like to live in in 20 years from
now but with visions needs to be
transformed into goals and targets an
example of goals turned into action is
our city planning project the stock
employer support area the area consists
of 236 hectares or mainly old industrial
land and ports that over the next 20
years is going to developed into 30,000
offices and 10,000 homes and this
project has a strong environmental
profiling the City Council have adopted
a comprehensive program covering goals
regarding ecological sustainability
social sustainability and reduction of
carbon emissions the program is
developed in close cooperation with the
stakeholders and all agree that the
Stockholm Royal seaport should be a
world-class area regarding
sustainability and I would like to give
you a few examples of these goals and
one is that by 2020 it has to the
exhaust or 1.5 ton of co2 emissions
per person and year and per year today
stockham overall had a 3.5 so this is
very very tough goal by 2030 the area is
to be fossil fuel free and within the
area there will be plus houses houses
that create more energy than the UN and
they use and pump it back and the energy
back into the main electric grid you
heard about smart grids this morning and
the development of the area will go on
for many years and is also divided into
smaller projects and for each project
the overriding goals will be transformed
into specific targets that the builders
have to meet and in this works this is
you have a close cooperation with the
building industry the companies and the
research areas the program also states
that the companies involved should have
the opportunity to use the area as a
showcase for the their technology and
excellent solutions as a result of
course the interest to be part of the
development of this area is very strong
from from business not only from Swedish
companies from international companies
also and there is a lot of interesting
collaboration projects going on and one
example of that is that the company ABB
is together with the local energy
company for term and the Royal Institute
of Technology and Ericsson involved in a
project about smart grid solutions in
this area and we also have connected to
the development a Stockholm royal
support innovation and the mission
furthermore for example to create a
venue for making contacts plan implement
evaluate and conduct research on
sustainable solutions being tested in
the Royal support area and to promote
the development and application of
environmental technologies and system
solutions for sustainable
Urban Development to show and
communicate knowledge on environmental
technologies and sustainable solutions
that help to influence Community
Planning businesses and users behaviors
to towards towards sustainability so
this is one example how we actually care
work very very close together with
businesses in Stockholm and we think
that the close cooperation between the
city and business is of great importance
and the main task for the city owned
company stock owned business region
development sbr d is to help increase
sustainable growth is sbr d focus on a
mainly of three areas investment
promotion development of stock a massive
business location and service to
industry tough draw a throw efforts in
these three areas the company will will
actually contribute to improving the
conditions for running launched and it's
the established businesses in stockholm
and in the stockholm region as well
since the conditions in the business
world are changing at an accelerating
rate we know all that sprd need
constantly updated data to identify
bottlenecks and need for the industry
and the role as a facilitator for
business academy and the public sector
needs to be strengthened primarily in
innovation and entrepreneurship and we
are working in that direction right now
Stockham has more than 20 business parks
with large differences but all of which
you serve a major hub for a different
type of activities required in the
divinity of the city in 2012 started
projects to actually define the
characteristics of a world-class
business park and the aim is to try to
describe what it takes to fulfill the
task for generating jobs be attractive
to in
national investment while providing
necessary service to business and
citizen since com the work is done of
course in collaboration with the
companies that are located in the
business area and the city
administration and we are also working
very hard in order to improve the
service to stock homes businesses via e
services that's of course if great
important in order to reduce bureaucracy
improve accessibility provide prompt
handling of cases and provide good and
comprehensive information to companies
and the service brings together advice
administration and contacts to end
entrepreneurs from the city and its
various activities in one place and the
development is now in full swing and the
launch will take place next year sbr d
also provides companies that want to
grow and establish themselves in
Stockholm qualified and free servicing
to find premises permission network
manpower and order other key
establishment conditions such as links
to relevant authorities we also provide
knowledge about the we're innovators can
turn for advice and support to realize
their business ideas and stock on
business regional region development is
continually working to build networks
with companies in Stockholm to quickly
assist them if them if problems arise or
simply to connect companies said that we
actually know exist but they can't
perhaps doesn't know that the other one
exists one example is the administration
of something that we call the climate
packed with that I myself started in
2007 that's the cooperation between the
city and the business sector with a view
to fulfill the objectives of the stock
coming by
mental program the pact consists today
of more than 150 company companies as
and it's growing constantly continuously
and the pact is an arena where you can
increase the exchange between companies
in environmental technology and thus
helps strengthen their capacity for a
new market and this is also an
opportunity for for company from
different branches actually to meet a
cross-border so this has become a quite
important area and to create interaction
between the city and the business
community we arrange an annual Stockholm
meeting and bringing together partitions
business and representatives from
culture and and the University of calm
and the aim is to foster great
cooperation and focus on common
challenges and the topics for the
meeting 2011 was invaded innovation
strategy for calm and the city do this
together with the arranged meeting
together with the Chamber of Commerce
and erics on the company city of
Stockholm is also partner in the
electron foundation electrum is pursuing
strategies to ensure continued growth in
cheese design city one of the world's
leading ICT clusters and a good egg a
good cooperation between research
academy city and business communities as
well as helping both domestic and
foreign companies to establish
themselves in the area and growth will
primarily take place within
research-based and innovative growth
companies based on the application of
ICT we also have an administration
advisory board attacks to the stock
owned business region development and
members consist of key representatives
of the stock owned business community so
and these are only some examples of what
we actually do in order to have a very
close cooperation between the city of
Stockholm and the businesses and I do
personally myself also make a company
visit every week in order to see
what's happening around the business
arena in Stockholm thank you thank you
so much finally our last speaker is
Kathryn Wylde you can read her formal
biography in the program she is
president and CEO of the nonprofit
partnership for New York City which is
our leading business organization Cathy
joined the partnership in 1982 serving
as the president and CEO of its the New
York City investment fund and the
Housing Partnership Development
Corporation and under her leadership the
partnership has played a major role in
the city's emergence as a premier global
center of commerce culture and
innovation a Cathy who really is an
internationally known expert in housing
economic development and urban policy I
can personally attest to that is also
the deputy chair of the board of the
federal reserve bank of new york and
serves on numerous boards and
commissions including new york city's
Economic Development Corporation prior
to joining the partnership Cathie worked
at anchor savings bank and Lutheran
Medical Center and was the read lead
redevelopment person in the federally
designated poverty area of sunset park
brooklyn she hails from Madison
Wisconsin although I think you really
are a new yorker by now and did her
undergraduate degree at Olaf College
kathy has been the single most important
person in the city of New York ensuring
cooperation between business and
government which is not an easy task and
I will let you in on a secret Kathy may
be a tough-minded business leader but
she understands the importance of New
York's diverse communities and the need
to support civil society she doesn't
believe it's about business against
everybody else or everybody against
business it's about this kind of
cooperation
that the partnership in bodies and for
those of you who might try and entice
Kathy to your city we're not letting her
leave New York it's really a personal
pleasure for me to introduce Kathy wild
welcome thank you so much Esther more
than generous I and and Thank You
Marjorie tivan from global partners for
bringing everybody together today I
haven't been to a lot of cities in the
world but I have been to both Cape Town
and Stockholm and they are wonderful
cities i had the privilege in 1991 of
going with a team that Mayor David
Dinkins took to cape town and
johannesburg to help nelson mandela
convinced the business community that he
was not anti-business and the mayor the
mayor took a team and it was just an
amazing week that we spent in South
Africa at a very important moment in its
history in Cape Town's one of the most
beautiful places I've ever been so and
stockholm i went with IBM when we were
trying to introduce congestion pricing
in new york and stockholm was a real
leader there in our new york-based
company international but new york-based
i should note with a new woman CEO and
IBM took a team of us to stockholm to
understand how they were solving these
problems in stockholm we do a report
with PricewaterhouseCoopers every year
ranking great world cities that have
capital markets but many other things
and stockholm always ranks high and this
year went up faster than any other city
in terms of its performance because of
its great livability and i know that
allah had in her position is
contributing a lot to that so
congratulations to you as well i was
going to talk briefly about three things
one the our organization that's
organized as a partnership it is a
private sector organization it is
business leaders it is led it's 200 CEOs
of international business organizations
some national mostly international and
their membership their their employees
but that
is our there are shareholders in our
nonprofit organization and we partner
with state and local government
sometimes national but that's a little
far away we're very parochial here but
we partner with the leaders of state and
local government with the leaders of
organized labor with many civic and
other organizations to try and come up
with the best public policies to build
our economy and to try and actually
invest in real projects to build our
economy we created a privately funded
investment fund that we can use as seed
money to invest in for-profit or
nonprofit activities unlike many
so-called social investment funds we've
been in business for more than 15 years
and we have a have paid all our costs
and have an internal rate of return of
more than three percent and given that
we invest in higher risk lower return
projects than anybody else will do
that's pretty good so that's sort of our
partnership role it was importantly
started by David Rockefeller who was a
citizen of the world but also very much
a citizen of New York and New York City
he in the in 1980 understood that
globalization of the economy meant that
cities had a unique role they were the
place that had the density the diversity
the major institutions the
transportation networks that cities in
fact looking forward to the 21st century
and the global economy we're going to
have a real great role and they were
very important to international business
as the platform for its growth he also
understood that New York City in 1980
was a mess it was coming out of near
bankruptcy
it was hugely high crime rates its
neighborhoods had burned down it had
lost more than a million people the the
middle class the workforce had basically
fled because we lost several hundred
thousand manufacturing jobs in a very
short period of time we went from having
78 world headquarters companies or
fortune 500 companies to 40 in a period
of less than a decade we were
hemorrhaging jobs and people talent we
were a real mess and so he understood
that the future of both New York City
and international business was
absolutely locked they needed the city
as a great platform and it was a lousy
platform in 1980 and so they had
business had to do something about it he
called it enlightened self-interest
which is a term I'm sure you're familiar
with but that's what the partnership is
about I sometimes call it the anti
chamber of commerce we are business
acting in the interests of the city and
hopefully the state over so over this
period of time we have worked on reform
of public education on rebuilding
burnt-out neighborhoods so that the
middle class and could come back and
we'd have the strength of our
communities to support a good workforce
we have worked on a number of projects
including trying unsuccessfully with
with the city to bring congestion
pricing in but to make sure that we had
the resources to fight crime to support
our public transportation system we are
a group that sometimes supports raising
taxes in order to do that as we did a
couple years ago with raising a mobility
tax to pay for our MTA so we work out a
number of those policy initiatives and
when it's important to figure out what
to do next to take some early risks we
use our investment fund to do that you
need only think about the consequences
for I don't know if you if you read
about we we read about it a lot here we
had
half a billion dollar investment that
our federal government made last year in
a factory to build solar panels in
California that went bust with the and
took the five hundred million dollars in
stimulus with it this has been a this is
an i just mentioned it as an
illustration of government has a hard
time taking early-stage risks and
picking winners because if they lose its
big trouble for the whoever made those
decisions on the other hand the private
sector has a risk/reward capacity that's
different that doesn't necessarily
depend on everything working and so
we've tried to position the private
sector is providing some resources to
take some of those risks that government
couldn't an example is in investing
early in the biotech industry in terms
of getting some of that activity going
and now that is a major new sector
that's developing in our city since I'm
going to be cut off when we're going to
go to questions I'm just going to
mention one other thing I wanted to talk
about we've also worked with the city
government as it has restructured itself
our city under Mayor Bloomberg figured
out that it is the private sector not
government that really has to be the job
creator the city has to provide the
environment they have to provide the
essential services and they have to
provide some responsiveness to the needs
of government and we've seen our city
government restructure its commitment to
business and business development in two
important ways that I just want to point
out one robert walsh the commissioner of
our department of Small Business
Services is sitting here in the front
row and I I just want to say that Mayor
Bloomberg created our first small
businesses services department on its
own because they very different demands
and needs from small business and large
business and very smartly put our
workforce training development workforce
training operation within that
because frankly big businesses have
human resources departments and the
training programs and all that small
businesses do not and need that kind of
support and so we've got that important
structure and then on the other side our
City Economic Development Corporation is
not technically a government agency
because it wouldn't have the freedom it
needed for procurement and for bringing
in resources for taking risks for for
helping for partnering with the private
sector as a government agency which is
hamstrung by so many rules and
regulations and it is set up as a
not-for-profit Local Development
Corporation and I think that that model
is one that has really made I've worked
with city government over the last 40
years in the last decade during which
these innovations were made in our
economic development area is really the
first time it's been successful in
partnering with the government's with
the private sector excuse me with
business so I would just suggest to you
that it's a very good model to take a
look at thank you
thank you very much Kathy I'd like to
invite members of the audience up to the
microphones for questions after you just
line up students in my class know you
know you'll get extra points if you ask
a good question if you don't I don't
know what I'm going to do but while
we're waiting for people to line up
because I know you will I'll present one
question to our panelists here you've
all touched on very important aspects of
the public-private partnership and
looking both at what government can do
for cities and what cities what
businesses rather can do for cities and
what city governments need to do for
business but at the end of the day we
all know business is about profit so in
keeping that in mind what is the most
command Cathy sort of touched on this
with the enlightened self-interest but I
like everybody to expand on this what is
really the most compelling reason for
business is to work with government and
and why don't I start with you Ola I
think that there is a lot of reasons and
if you're looking historically upon so
calm and our development so you can
actually see that where one important
reason why we became the first european
green capital in 2010 appointed by the
european commission was the smart
solutions developed by the companies and
provided to the city and they've been
able to to market that good ideas and to
sell their knowledge all over the world
thanks to the development in stockholm
and that's what we are doing right now
in this token bryci poor area as well
because i think it's important if you
would like to keep the position as one
of the leading cities in the world
business do you understand that they can
help and that's also business for
them if they can help us to make smart
solutions and that's what we actually
are doing when we are working together
with the business in the air in the
stock amravati port area and this is
really a win-win situation thank you
Chris but I think for us as a as a min a
small organization it is it's critical
in working with government I think as a
as a social enterprise we share the same
objectives with government and that is
in our particular environment is to
create a better life for all I think
there's a lot of initiatives I can think
of for example the Cape Town activer
entrepreneurship initiative which has
been looking at the barcelona activa
model and how do we implement that in
captain and how do we adapt it as active
as done with so many countries all over
the wall and I think the progressive
thinking of the city in this case is
that they do not have the resources to
do this by themselves so they act as the
as the catalyst to make this happen and
they then leave it over to private
business and private sector to drive and
really implement those initiatives
because we are closer to the ground and
I mean some of the resources might be
more easily available to private sector
to to do but for me personally and for
our our organization it comes to very
much to sharing the the same objectives
in the end of the day Kathy well as i
alluded the when the city doesn't work
business can't function so it's a it's
it's a total total identity of interest
in terms of business having a vested
interest in the city working it's
totally in business interests when they
put in a call because something is
broken down that somebody smart and good
and highly motivated working for the
city is on the other end of the phone so
they have they have lots of reasons to
want a city that works a generation ago
businesses fled the city and went out to
suburban office parks or to other places
in the world and thought they could
ignore their partnership with government
and but fortunately the forces of the
21st century are bringing people and
business back to the city they have to
have the diversity of talent the
resources of the wonderful research and
academic institutions that are mostly in
cities and so in the infrastructure
transportation international airports
etc so they're coming back to the city
and their stake in the city is only
growing larger thank you while we were
chatting up here I noticed that we have
some questions so what I'd like to do is
ask our questioners one at a time to
present their questions and then the
panelists can divvy them up and we can
hear from everybody so why don't we
start and please identify yourself sure
my name is southern belle I work in the
Middle East North Africa region of the
world bank the title of this panel
session is business growth and job
creation and and the research we've done
at the bank seems to suggest that
something between fifteen to twenty
percent of firms generate lots of jobs
rapidly the rest actually have a certain
amount of jobs and they stay at that
level for long periods of time so my
question really is is there any efforts
made and I think you know we're in a
situation where global unemployment is
an increasingly serious problem for
ourselves here in Europe and and all
around the world and we're now seemingly
staring in the face of us potentially a
second global financial crisis which
could make things worse so I guess my
question to you is anything done to
actually focus on the types of
industries that would fall into perhaps
that fifteen to twenty percent which are
rapid employment generators or is it
just a policy of supporting all
businesses in the hope that overall in
plone will increase Thanks thank you hi
my name is nina robbins i work at
columbia university and my question is
about public-private partnerships that
have not worked
looking at infrastructure projects that
have gone under and kind of put a damper
on the concept when it was very popular
and what kind of structural what kind of
structured you need in a private public
partnership and what kind of conditions
make for a success that can be shared
thank you hello my name is Zeb Landsman
um I've noticed that our political world
there's a big fight between some that
say regulation is good and some would
say regulations bad it's I'm say free
market yes and free market know I've
always thought that's a stupid
distinction because private industry
can't function without government
someone needs to enforce the contracts
someone needs to protect the patents
someone needs to build roads and I love
some way to change the conversation from
yes free market and yes regulation to
discussing the individual regulation and
which ones work rather than just kind of
choosing up teams I'm wondering how to
do that thank you yes hi I wanted to
pick up on a point that Kathy mentioned
regarding a three percent return on your
investments um if you can share with us
how you do that because you know we're
struggling to monetize social problems
you know we want to fund a cure for
cancer or we want to fund transportation
but we can't seem to get the dollars to
do so so I would love to see how your
organization funds these problems things
okay smitha sreenivas I'm a faculty
member here in urban planning and I
direct the technological change lab at
columbia university my question to the
panelists is related to the issue that
mr. malta raise this morning which is
that a big form of economic dynamism
will come from companies that are
directly innovating in areas that are
public concern so sort of a social goods
focus for technological innovation and
my question to you the three panelist is
what are two three
perhaps in your cities that you have
done to prioritize those social goals as
a signal for technological innovation
thank you thank you what I'd like to do
since you've all heard all five of these
questions is make sure we try and cover
in some way all of them but there are
only three of you so I am some of them
were directed to individuals but i'm not
going to divvy up these questions but
i'm going to ask each of you to address
aspects of the questions that you think
when we're most pertinent to your work
and if something gets left out we'll try
and circle back and get a response so
I'm going to ask at this point Chris to
begin is that I think in terms of the
the questioner gentleman over there with
job creation i think the latest
statistics that we have is it fifty
percent of all new jobs are created by
small business so that is a very
important sector 44 no for government to
develop into focus and there seems to be
there's very very heavy expectation that
this stage that entrepreneurship is the
golden key and the golden solution in
our particular environment to solve most
of the social issues and i'm i'm afraid
that in in many sense that that it is
not that entrepreneurship in itself does
not address some of the underlying
problems that we have that's going to
create a better society so that's
something that we know that one has to
be very careful about in in looking at
entrepreneurship and small business as
being the sole provider of of new
opportunity and new jobs Thank You Ola
yeah and it's a great challenge to sort
of attract small businesses to employ
people because that's a of course risk
taking all the time but
I think it's important that the city
show good examples where you actually
can show that we have small companies
that has developed quite rapidly and
that they are good example for other
companies as well and we also have a
startup advice system where we actually
also advise companies how to grow in a
sustainable way and we have that kind of
advice are we working together with
their with the finance sector and others
consultant company so that's a free of
charge advisory for a lot of SME
companies and we also have a system in
stock on call the stock of innovation
and growth company where we actually
have a business angel system connected
to a fund where we approve companies
that have a business idea that's good
enough for exporting we don't take
companies that don't have a export idea
but but companies that actually have
good ideas that it's possible to export
they can have these funds and they can
also be part of the business networking
business angel networks and have all the
kind of advices that the oldest
experience people have so this is also
one way of supporting a possibility to
grow in and when we talk about SME
companies Cathy well i think in you know
our organic growth in jobs in new york
city over the last 10 years has been
business and professional services in
the health care industry is the biggest
generator of jobs that's obviously not
the source of next generation new job
well I won't say that about health care
but private sector in private sector job
creation on and both of those depend on
other sources of revenues and markets
from other industries so we've been
clearly
everybody knows that industry cluster
development creating the infrastructure
and providing the kind of public and
private support is the key to that I
think cities have the unique advantage
in that we also have the markets to do
the early beta testing the adoption and
what we've tried to do in New York City
is structure programs that greatly
accelerate an advantage entrepreneurial
efforts growing here by virtue of their
support partnership early access to
markets from our major legacy companies
in the media sector of course first with
the digital media sector where we have
built a world-class culture with tens of
thousands of jobs in at this point and
but also in creasing Lee in other
sectors of our economy thank you the one
question that clearly didn't get
responded to really came up in two of
the last questions which is about social
innovation and prioritizing social goals
and I think that I'm going to take the
moderators prerogative and make a point
here I one fascinated by that question
because it is an interesting time that
we live in when we're looking to the
private sector to do what traditionally
has been government's function so i
would like to rephrase that and maybe
you know this is this is a failure of
the whole civic conversation but
business schools have taken up this
issue of social entrepreneurship and i
think they've been very innovative there
are public policy school has been
working with the private sector to
encourage students to work in the area
of social entrepreneurship as well in
reality I believe that we're not going
to solve social problems without both
government doing what it needs to do
which is educate this next generation so
that they can take up the jobs and don't
require the services and then provide
the service
is for those who are as some used to say
the truly needy there's a charitable SEC
sector and they have responsibilities
but the real responsibility in that
field is government and our focus today
has been really how government can help
business in the job creation and
business development area and I just
want to thank our panelists for focusing
on the point of the conference and
really providing for us you know
tremendous examples if you're listening
and you're from other cities I think
some trade secrets have been revealed
here today and I hope you take them home
with with you and this has been a great
way to end our morning session thank you
so much